ich habe in diesem tiktok Video gesehen
dass man anscheinend wenn man eine
Knoblauchzehe anfasst ein Eigelb aus dem
Eiweiß rausheben kann und das probieren
wir aus hi aufschlagen
Zack und jetzt ihr kennt das vielleicht
wenn ihr viel mit Knoblauch arbeitet man
hat manchmal so klebrige Finger haben
wir unsere Finger einfach ein bisschen
über die Oberfläche so und jetzt
angeblich die beiden Finger die gerade
noch am Knoblauch waren gehen jetzt rein
ans Eigelb
ah perfekt klappt ja wirklich super das
Ding ist selbst wenn es geklappt hätte
wofür soll das gut sein damit man Baiser
machen kann dass er Knoblauch schmeckt
zweiter Versuch war jetzt gerade habe
ich dieses kleben zwischen den Fingern
nee ist einfach nur scheiße bringt gar
nichts